there is nothing here but
suffering pain
and suffering it is time to go
barry i'll start with you because i've
already spoken to everyone in the cast
and
i will say that everyone pretty much
admitted the reason why they signed on
was to get to work with you both by
reputation and then just by what you did
which is a huge testament but
this has been a long-term passion
project of yours so
walk us through when you first sort of
wanted to
adapt this pulitzer prize-winning novel
and then how you were able to finally
get it to the screen
yeah i guess it began when i was a kid
and i heard the
the words underground railroad and you
know i saw black people
on trains underground i just it was real
to me
um and i've always held on to that
feeling and
i was a big fan of colson whitehead's
work i tried to option his first book
the intuitionist um didn't get that one
when i heard that he had written a book
titled the underground railroad
i just knew he had done something
something that was different with it
um and then i read the book and those
suspicions were confirmed
this was even before uh moonlight
premiered a telluride
um i said to my reps you know we got to
get to this guy
because i have to adapt this book um and
it has to be a series
um not a feature and so it started i
guess five years ago now the the whole
process
oh wow that's incredible um and two so
you this is your first
big like leading work reading
film and i'm just curious um the casting
process because
to barry's testament he loves getting
new faces
and so i love that you're involved in
this but i mean that's gotta be crazy
first shot out the gate let's talk about
it i i started the process
in november 2018 when i first got the
brief
and for me it was really about you know
taking in this this because i all i had
were the sites i didn't know that it was
based on a book at the time
and seeing something that i knew would
personally
challenge me in my craft and that come
what may i would grow from it
so i went and i auditioned but i put it
at the back of my mind because i was
like first of all i don't even have the
accent
but i'm still gonna put my best foot
forward performance wise
you know and hoping that they would see
me
and kind of keep me in mind for
something else in the future you know
and then in 20 like 2019 january 2019
i'd taken time off just to you know come
to the states for the first two and a
half months
and it was a case again of i'm gonna
learn as much as i can
while i'm here and if even if nothing
comes from it i know that it's stuff
that i can use back in south africa
so i got into a work session with
francine maisler who was the
was the casting director for the show we
worked she challenged and pulled me left
and right
and then that evening i was told that it
was a call back and that barry wanted to
meet me i made barry the next evening
and we just had a conversation just you
know just just about anything and
everything
and that's when i found out that it was
about it was based on a book
and so in those two weeks before the
test shoot i then
read the book like two and a half times
to to make sure that i was more than
prepared
by the time it came to the final
audition wow that's incredible
um barry i have to ask you about it
because
i know how you do casting and how
dedicated you are
to finding the right face whether it be
their first or their fifth feature
um talk about how you knew that she was
the one to sort of be
our avatar through this journey um
across this sort of
episodic story yeah it was uh i think
sometimes it's a feeling you know
and i think anyone uh can walk in
if you can show me the character and
give me that feeling then the role
um is yours uh with twoso it was very
clear
you know for a character like this if
you're if you're creating it with
fidelity to the period
you know the idea of expressing herself
uh
verbally or externally um you know
that is very checked you know this
person doesn't have full possession of a
personhood but internally
has complete possession you know of
their personhood
so i was looking for someone who as you
said you used more avatar i think it's a
beautiful way of describing it
because so much of what korra is feeling
tucson has to express you know through
body language or through very
subtle facial gestures not big facial
gestures because you have to communicate
out in the open without the
communication being noticeable
um and i i could just tell brother tuso
um had all those things uh in droves
i didn't realize you know how much
she uh related to the character i didn't
realize
i couldn't know how much work she would
do um
to to build um the character um in her
own
time um you know she's one of the
hardest working women in show business
and we're always working human beings in
show business
um and i just knew i could just feel it
i love that
um it's the testaments in in the what we
saw because i was expected to go ahead
and see it and so i
i can't i can't say i can't wait for
folks to see this because
it's very like hard watch but i can't
wait for them to see
your beautiful performance and what you
guys were able to create
scored by everything that nick did um i
have to talk about nicholas patel
because i think you know i'm the biggest
queen of
the two of y'all staying close together
seriously though but the two of y'all
collaborating but not just him
joy came back to this and and so many of
the moonlight folks from the
cinematography
it's important to you to bring back
these collaborators and
what was it like switching it up to
episodic did it feel the same or did you
have to come up with some new shorthand
for this type of storytelling no it felt
the same or we strove to make it feel
the same
the only difference is the amount of
time you have to to create every
experience
you know i think a feature film is a
very bespoke experience
because you have so much time to focus
on you know a very small
amount of details given as you're
dealing with 100 pages this is like
500 pages um and so it's kind of harder
to tailor
each each moment uh the way you normally
would but
i think having the same creative team uh
the shorthand
um that that's implicit in that allows
you to cover
more ground and so we try to approach it
the same way
i also thing too because the subject
matter
is so heavy i think being surrounded by
people who you know
who you love who care about you and who
care about you and who love you
it makes that work i don't know it just
not that it made it easier
but it just made it more achievable and
so i do think i don't know that we could
have made this show without this
collection of people
at least not in the way or with the
energy that we made it yeah
you know when i first started this i was
talking to folks about you know the toll
of the shoot but everyone came back with
yeah you know it was but barry put a lot
of
guard rails in place with advisors but
the thing everybody talked about too so
was the fact that it created this sort
of like gallows humor
amongst the cast and that you guys
really felt the need to turn up
off camera so i want to talk about that
now i want to talk about
how you guys are able to laugh through
the gravity of what you had to do every
day i think william said he's like
lungs didn't compromise what we had to
do on camera we were cutting up
no 100 percent 100 100 100 i even have a
video
where i randomly pulled barry aside and
i'm with william
and i made us do the wave
[Laughter]
i'm actually waiting for the perfect
time to post that video but that was you
know
the general energy like we were very
aware of what it is that we were
creating very respectful of it but we
did what we needed to do in between the
moments to take care of each other
and one of that was just enjoying each
other's company
you know whether it be onset in between
the moments
i had a thing where i went around you
know breaking people's knees
because you know something a little bit
tense you know and then on weekends
going out for bowling going to the beach
and just being comfortable in each
other's space like that
that for me was a very it was a
difference maker
i don't know i want that right i'm gonna
post it
i want that video do it do what you do
man do what you do hey i got some videos
and photos too all right
i love it i love it uh aaron told me
that it went down in the dms to begin
as far as you guys first contacting each
other oh no
i'm the one that reached out to him
first because i'd already arrived in
savannah
and so i was just like oh you're
arriving tomorrow
hey hey hey i didn't want it to be like
you know that awkward first meeting
you know just break the ice and we
clicked instantly
we definitely talked about magical
realism in this
and if you could just quickly tell me
how you were able to sort of balance the
fantastical element of the story
being the real real world as opposed to
a network of people
and the realities of everything that you
kind of had to portray on screen and
and do both authentically yeah i think
part of it was just through research
i mean you know uh we we when we talk
about
afrofuturism we always think of it as
people um in space or sun ra
and things like that but i look at my
ancestors and through the research
i think of the afrofuturism of what they
must have gone through
their bodies were restricted which means
their minds must have been so
completely activated and so i was
always trying to find these very
grounded these very tactile
symbols that could be carried from one
place to another
and in them being either passed on from
generation to generation or traveling
from one place to another place
they kind of gain this almost sublimated
um
experience you know you you take these
things that are around you
and you create the spiritual buffer you
need so that these people can endure so
that
myself and jacqueline can sit here in
2021 and have this conversation about
this piece of art designed to honor them
and so yeah it was one of those things
that i was always trying to be aware of
i told our production designer trains
are not going to levitate
in this show but we are going to
sublimate them
we are going to supplement them and that
was always a through line
man lost my mom then me
and noah he ever given up on finding me
i have to say you know obviously
barry is such an incredible filmmaker
and although this is his first foray
into television
i imagine it was quite incredible to get
cast in it knowing you know this is the
man who made moonlight
and beale street and he was bringing all
of those folks into this one as well
yeah i mean the second my agent was like
barry jenkins oh yeah yeah yes yes
that's the first thing i said
and i was like of course like i don't
you know i
there's there's no way i'm not gonna do
this um but you know on a serious note i
think to i hadn't read the book
when i got approached um but it was on
my to read list i was aware of it so it
gave me an incentive to read it
um but particularly after i read it i
just had no doubt in my mind that he was
the right person
to adapt something like this because he
has such a brilliant sensitivity when it
comes
to um telling stories
about difficult things about black
people you know
and and and he tells it in such a kind
of
special way um that i yeah i was i was
there i was there before he even knew i
was there
you know yeah and like i said because
it's barry jenkins of course he's gonna
assemble this
incredible cast um of folks um
but that being said this is very
sensitive material
and i know that they were very
thoughtful on making sure that everybody
on set
didn't let the toll of what you're
having to portray on screen sort of take
it at home
so talk about that i heard there was
therapy advisors on set that there was a
real
again just a sensitivity to yes we're
going to be showing black pain but
we don't want it to be exploitative yeah
absolutely and
and like you said there were there were
councillors there were there were
numbers to call
um barry warned us before we went to the
plantation said that it looked very real
and he made a real point of saying to
people be prepared because it looks real
and it did
you know and he was aware that the the
even just the visuals of something or
being suddenly in that environment can
be extremely triggering
you know um but also he he was always
checking in with everyone
you know after each take and and we were
checking in with each other as well
um so there was a real vibe on set that
made sure that everyone knew that it was
our group responsibility to look after
each other and ourselves
which was so important because you know
none of us wanted to take this
on into our lives but it was important
that we were able to feel safe enough
to um really jump into the deep end with
the work
you know and make sure that we were
really
doing the story justice doing the people
justice as well doing the memories of
those people justice
um so yeah that that was
one of the best experiences i've had in
terms of um
care on set and consideration for the
team
i love that and it's necessary obviously
with such
weighty material i mean this is based on
a pulitzer prize-winning
uh novel in which uh magical realism
is is how it's sort of thought because
the underground railroad is an actual
railroad in this and there's a lot of
expandings of what we consider real but
it's also
completely exactly the things that
happen and i was just curious
sort of set the stage for folks on how
you guys are going to
make that balance between the sort of
imagined and the real life people
and um what they should expect i
think what's so great about um
the magical realism in this is that the
magic kind of speaks for itself
and that the characters don't really
have to do anything magical they're just
people you know they're just people
who um you know there's there's a
railroad
and there's a there's a train in it and
it's real um
and i think actually it's more important
for us to really
engage with it as something that is real
um because
that is where you get the true humanity
of these characters and that's where you
get
the authenticity of them and that's
where you don't lose the gravity of the
actual story is you're saying you know
this is
that there are so many elements of this
story that are true and
i think it's important to make sure that
those are prioritized and preserved
and that the magical aspect of the story
particularly in terms of the train
um is something that comes in to
actually support
the story rather than to overtake it and
i really feel like it does that i feel
like
there's something so extraordinary about
being able to see
what essentially was just a network of
people
in the real story of the underground
railroad um manifested into this kind of
physical thing but i think it's
definitely coming from
the true story rather than something
that's being imposed on top you know
so it still feels grounded and rooted in
something
authentic nothing
was given
all was earned working with barry though
i'm just curious after you know
moonlight i would imagine you know he
can pretty much do whatever he wants and
so what was it like getting the call
to know that you're going to be working
with him on his next project
yeah that's a great question um that was
such an a surreal moment for me and
it's actually a really uh interesting
story the way that he actually even
discovered me because he
had flown to the uk
uh to see andre holland at the globe
theater as othello
and it just so happened that i was also
in that show
playing cassio which is othello's
lieutenant
and that's how he even discovered who i
was and he sent me a direct message on
twitter
and just showed his love and support
you know an appreciation for what you
know the cast did and said
in a nutshell i'd love to connect and
make something happen
and then over a certain amount of time
the underground railroad happened and
the rest is history it was it was a
dream come true and it still is a dream
come true
it goes down in the damn that actually
makes me feel better about keeping
social media just a little bit
honestly uh jokes aside um
this was not um an easy endeavor that's
why i wanted to go ahead and frame it as
it was because
as beautiful as everything that y'all
created um
i know it had to take a toll that you
know berries talked about it they had
onset therapy advisors
just physically being a black person
walking onto a plantation that looks
authentically staged as it did back then
is a toll and even more so i would
imagine
as black brit and and that added part of
going to
you know sending in an american setting
to this to this
uh you know scene of bondage how did you
guys tackle that and
and approach it every day what what
you you just touched on something that
was really important
during this whole project you know barry
created such a safe and supportive
environment for everybody
and handled everything with such care
um and sensitivity you know he ensured
that we had a guidance counselor on set
at all times
and you know irrespective of whether you
utilize that service or not
it's just the knowing that it's there
that gives you a sense of calm and
that comes from knowing that if ever
anything gets too much
or too overwhelming there is someone who
can help you out of that space
and yes it was very very
very challenging and upsetting
and harrowing and at the same time
you know i reflected on the magnitude of
strength that these people
had in order to overcome and enjoy these
circumstances
um and ultimately yeah just overcome it
yeah and the purpose for it you know
i think will be seen when folks see it
because this is a story that's
a magical realistic tale about the real
things of the underground railroad but
it's portrayed as if it was an
actual railroad and i'm just curious
there's a suspension of disbelief you
have to take in some aspects of the
story but then there's some completely
you can't shy away from it absolutely
brutally realistic aspects to it
and i'm just curious is that more
difficult than doing something high
fantasy like krypton
or even maybe old a horror or is this
more difficult that that delicate
balance of magical realism where maybe
only
certain smaller aspects are sort of
shifted for the storytelling i think
for me personally i think
dealing with subject matter like this is
always going to be
the most challenging for me um and the
most sensitive for me
um because
it's because it's connected to
the diaspora you know and this is this
is a story about the african-american
experience specifically um
but that still i still feel a connection
to that and i still feel
um deeply saddened that this was an
experience that
the diaspora had so it was very
challenging and very uncomfortable
and i think that will always be the most
challenging
stories to take on
i have to say with this one as a
filmmaker yourself i would imagine
working with barry was a huge draw to
signing up to do this one so
talk about working with him and what
made you want to sign on
well you know i'd heard through the
grapevine
and conversations with actors and crew
how much they loved working
with barry and i love the things that he
makes
so when i heard about underground
railroad i actually
i actually railroaded barry i was like
came up to him at an event and i was
like
hey man uh i've heard about the
this thing that you want to make and you
know i'm i'm
really basically i was telling him i
want to i would like to work with you
and
and then i read the material and i was
like do i really
you know do i really want to work with
him if i have to do this
you know yeah but but but i really trust
him i trusted the material i trusted the
extra
insights that we get into ridgeway that
don't make us want to sympathise with
him
but help us to understand how a person
could be shaped
that made it all worthwhile yeah you
bring me to my next question which is
with any work like this being the
character that you're playing let's be
honest the biggest racist
most just visceral person on the screen
antagonizing these folks in a lot of
these things
it's difficult to say yes to it but and
more importantly i know it was a tough
shoot for everyone but
but how did you balance that on set
because i know speaking with fassbender
and youngo both of them talked about how
they had sort of an unspoken language of
how they dealt with it every day
they would they wouldn't say anything to
each other but they give each other like
a hand signal to say
i know yeah we had to really look after
each other i think
you know i i would go to work i could do
these terrible things
but then i was always reminded that tusa
and other actors
had to have those terrible things done
to them
um which i think is worse you know in
the in the pretend aspect of it all
none of it's fun um that said there's a
lot of fun
there's a lot of joy and a lot of love
in the show as well and it's not
i think it's good for audiences to know
it's not all
bleak it's interesting though i i am uh
you know michael fassbender and i did
have a talk about this
um because he said oh look i i did it
for the space of one movie
and he said good luck inhabiting that
headspace for
six months it was like eight months i
think
and i didn't really know the gravity of
what he was saying until i was sort of
deeper into it
and is realizing yeah it was it was
tough but we all looked after each other
you know that that was the spirit
of the team was that you know i wasn't
able to sustain keeping to myself
i had a really close little pod
relationship with homer with with
beautiful chase dylan but we could
enjoy each other in between cut and the
next action
and then terrorize each other in between
action that's the aussie in you
you gotta go have a bevy i guess
afterwards to make sure everyone gets
back together um yeah
it's definitely gallows humor it's
soldier humor it's like
dealing with terrible things through
sarcasm and and irony and
a little bit of joke joke but we all
knew that we were pushing
down some awful stuff too all right
they're wrapping me i know you're not
going to tell me anything about obi-wan
anyway but
tell me something to make folks excited
about it
can you put the look it's
it's uh it's exciting i just think it's
exciting that
we get to revisit that material i i
actually don't know a lot and if i knew
it and i told you
you'd have to kill me they'd probably
kill me and i'd have to kill you but i'd
have to kill you first otherwise
thank you i think they're just excited
to keep it is a surprise for the
audience i think that's what why
all the secrecy so we can all watch it
rather than talk about it beforehand but
you came all this way on the railroad
yeah left behind all those peoples
we talked a little bit about this before
but really talk about working with barry
because
you're like one of my last interviews
everyone talked about that was the first
reason why they signed up was just
i wanted to work with him and then talk
about him sort of guiding you through
this
on set well um yeah
of course like count me as another one
of those people that really wanted to
work with him because i
really did but i think you know the
thing about barry is that he's such a
normal down-to-earth guy but he's got
the brain
of uh deity you know it's like
this is like this is the kind of man
that like you know
he collaborates he's very open and he's
very
calm and um and still
has a very specific vision
and he's always thinking he's always
trying to find ways to tell the story
and refine the story and to
find new ways that will fit into this
world that he's sort of crafted and
it's um it's it's it's incredible to to
see a mind like that
at work and to just be there while it's
uh while it's firing on all cylinders
you know
what's interesting too is for much of
the cast these are folks that he's
working with
kind of for the first time but behind
the scenes he brings so many
familiar faces from the moonlight world
i mean he brought back nicholas patel
and joy did you guys see that on set
folks that
from the behind the scenes aspect had
worked with barry for years and and what
did they say about this idea that they
keep signing up to do his projects
um you know i i didn't like i didn't
always
connect the dots just because i needed
to
i needed to not be scared of people um
it's easy for me to get intimidated
and i mean i'm often very intimidated
and i was very intimidated by barry for
a while and you know i i eventually was
just like you know i think it's a good
thing that i don't know
everyone's story that we're just in this
moment trying to make this thing
and um so
if i did encounter people on set that
had worked with barry previously i
didn't know about it until
way after the fact you know i just sort
of like i
all you all have made things that have
been so effective to me
um i cannot i i can only
i only have room for so much
intimidation for so many people in one
day and
i i kind of need to just keep the slate
pretty blank
well i'm actually kind of glad to hear
that because as a writer just writing
about barry's work the first time i
wrote about moonlight i had like a mini
panic attack so that is
just so assuring because i was like i
don't have the words to convey to people
how awesome this man is
and i think they should find another
writer so i really love that you walked
on so with that same energy because i
think
it's it's testament to how awesome he is
um
i will say this though too um you know
it's not an easy shoot you know barry
talked about that having the advisors
and having everyone sort of there but
when i spoke to joel
he also talked about how everybody
developed a bit of almost like
soldier humor and gallows humor because
they needed to escape from it too and i
would imagine that was maybe
something that you probably maybe
gravitated towards too so what were you
doing
to keep it light on the outside because
i know if i was in it
just knowing my own personal anxiety i'd
be like every comedy special ever made
is gonna be my daily playlist
yeah you know we um i mean honestly it's
like on set we did just
very much shake it out in between takes
as long as it didn't compromise the
integrity of the scene but then
on top of that we hung out
as the cast a lot doing real
dumb fun stuff you know like we would go
bowling we go to
topgolf and throw our clubs out in the
middle of the green because we can't
golf
and you know sing karaoke i mean like we
did a lot
of that stuff to sort of just connect
and to sort of live in the joy because
the other thing is like there is a lot
of
joy in the story in the midst of
something that is so heavy there are
moments that are
joyful and i think that we i feel like
i needed to cling to those as much as
i could just so my mind would stay
right um and then i i could i could just
sort of
get through the next day so it's uh yeah
but joel's absolutely right there was a
lot of odd humor that made its way
into into the into the the world that we
were all playing in
well i like that and i would have done
the same thing they're wrapping me but i
definitely want to get leave you on on
this part too
there's a lot of slave narratives that
have been out there i mean
oscar-winning ones and very important
ones what would you say to folks about
this one that makes it
different and why they should still tune
in on it because some folks would say do
we do we need another and i know
having seen it they absolutely do
well i think the first thing is um you
know take care of yourself
that's job one you know like we're all
going through a lot
take care of yourself um
it is my hope that eventually
folks can watch it and i hope we can
like start to push some really difficult
conversations
about who we would have been in that
moment and who we are in this moment
that we're living through
because i think we all would like to
think that we would have been
abolitionists and we would not have been
and there's many injustices that i see
that i'm not doing anything about
but i know it's wrong and so and i mean
like i'm hoping that you know it's like
and look
this thing lives online if you can't do
it right now
that's fine take your time the but at
the core of it i think it's take care of
yourself
that's that's what i hope people
do and i hope people watch it when
they're ready it's there
when they feel like it
what belongs to you
you